millions de dollars d'aidé militaire une
enveloppe destinée au gouvernement
ukrainien pour repousser les troupes
russes du dombass elle vient s'ajouter
aux quelque 2 6 milliards de dollars
déjà administré à la défense ukrainienne
cette enveloppe comprend des armes
d'artillerie lourde des dizaines d'obus
zee avec 144 mille versions elle
comprend également des drones au cours
des deux derniers mois nous avons
acheminé des armes et du matériel vers
l'ukraine à une vitesse record
autres aides envisagées par washington
un fonds de 500 millions de dollars pour
permettre au gouvernement ukrainien de
payer les salaires et les retraites des
fonctionnaires et continuer à assurer
les services publics le président
américain a également annoncé des
sanctions contre les navires liée à la
russie ils seront désormais interdits
dans les ports américains les européens
ont pris une mesure similaire il ya deux
semaines
cela signifie qu'aucun navire qui
navigue sous pavillon russe ou qui est
détenu ou exploités par des intérêts
russes ne sera autorisé à jeter l'ancré
dans les ports américains et sur nos
côtes
joe biden a indiqué qu'il allait
demander des fonds supplémentaires au
congrès américain il le promet aux
ukrainien vladimir poutine ne réussira
jamais à occuper d'ukraine